this video is sponsored by brilliant org
it's the 1970s Star Wars has just come
out disco is cool and scientists are
saying that we might all freeze to death
due to global cooling that's right
before the current focus by scientists
in the media on global warming they used
to be more worried about the potential
of the earth entering a new Ice Age two
scientists George Cutler and Robert
Matthews even went so far as to write a
letter to President Nixon warning him
that we may be about to see
unprecedented cooling human induced
change to the world's climate sound
familiar so why did scientists change
their minds so spectacularly what made
them flip from global cooling to global
warming
whatever happened to global cooling the
thing about the 1970s is that as well as
being desperately uncool it was when
climate research began to really mature
into a modern research field the Earth's
climate has been studied academically
arguably since the 11th century in China
and mathematically since the work of
Joseph Fourier in the 18th century when
he discovered the greenhouse effect but
in the early 20th century things notably
gathered pace as more and more physical
principles of how the atmosphere the
ocean and the Sun
interact were understood through more
and more studies and by the 1970s more
and more data was becoming available in
particular the first reconstructions of
the Earth's global average temperature
and the first continuous measurements of
carbon dioxide in the Earth's atmosphere
that data was being studied by lots of
different groups of scientists and they
didn't all agree on what they found
climate science isn't a single thing
there are loads of subfields that make
it up it's the same with most scientific
disciplines so imagine if Simon and I
weren't atmospheric physicists but
instead were rocket scientists now
firstly wouldn't that be awesome but
secondly even if Simon and I were
working on and understood the same
rocket he might be focused on liftoff
and I might be researching steering well
there are plenty of aspects of the
climate that
searchers figure out to theirs observing
the climate weather that's what's
happening today or digging into what
happened many thousands of years ago
you've got Milankovitch cycles which is
the influence that the Earth's orbit has
on its climate then you've got things
like aerosol science investigating these
tiny particles and which ones heat and
which ones cool the planet as well as
the influence that they have on clouds
and then of course we've got the side of
climate science that we hear the most
about greenhouse gases gases like carbon
dioxide and methane absorbed the longer
wavelength light that is emitted by
earth these are just some of the many
many sides of climate science that
researchers study and I feel like I'm
probably pissing off some of my friends
by forgetting to mention their specific
sub discipline if you want a rocket that
can both lift off and avoid crashing
into the moon then you need lots of
different rocket scientists and if you
want to understand the climate properly
then you need lots of different
subfields together all these things tell
us how the climate will respond when the
earth goes through changes say the Sun
gets brighter and hotter
how will the Earth's climate changed
then or say humans emit loads of
greenhouse gases and aerosols into the
atmosphere what happens then in the
1970s these research fields were worked
on mostly in isolation from one another
and there were four key groups of
scientists working at the time those
looking at global average temperatures
those looking at geology those looking
at aerosols and those studying the so
called greenhouse gases and these
different groups of scientists came to
some shocking conclusions the first
reconstruction of global average
temperatures to show a cooling trend was
published in 1963 by John Murray
Mitchell what he did was take
measurements from over 200 different
measuring stations run by the World
Meteorological Organization and combine
them into a global average we found was
that from the start of the record by
1880 running up till about 1940 the
world had warmed slightly
then from 1940 up until the time of
publication in 63 the world had cooled
by the time the seventies rocked up it
was widely accepted that the world had
cooled since about 1940 and when new
satellite observations came out this was
backed up because ice was growing all
over the northern hemisphere at the same
time geologists were realizing that the
earth had gone through periods of
extraordinary climate change in the past
up until the mid 20th century the
working theory of geologists was that
there have been a few short ice ages in
the recent past with long warm periods
between them but work by scientists like
Wallace broker and sassari Emiliana
showed that actually the past contained
long periods of the earth being covered
by ice sheets with relatively short
interglacials taking place between these
periods further these ice ages were
caused by slight variations in the
Earth's orbit around the Sun as
described mathematically by serbian
scientist Milutin Milankovitch his
theory published back in 1930 was
originally discredited because it just
didn't match with the record of past
climate but with the discovery of these
extensive extended ice ages it became
clear that he was right all along
a group of scientists led by James Hayes
using Milankovitch as mathematics
predicted that the long-term trend over
the next several thousand years is
towards extensive northern hemisphere
clacey ation in other words that we
would you to slip into a new ice age at
some point in the next several thousand
years so one group of scientists had
found that the earth had been cooling
for several decades and another group of
scientists have found that the earth was
due to enter a new ice age but things
got really tasty when we added humans
into the mix the third group the
scientists studying aerosols those are
these small little particles like Cert
or dust or salt found that human
economic activity had increased the
amount of aerosols in the atmosphere and
crucially that the more aerosols that
are in the atmosphere less of the sun's
radiation is reaching the surface or in
other words human economic activity
increasing the number of aerosols in the
atmosphere had
coold the earth and that anthropogenic
cooling might be enough to push the
earth into its next predicted ice age
it's a smoking gun global cooling it's
gonna happen certainly how the press at
the time reported this so why did
scientists stop with the global cooling
narrative in this graph you can see the
number of papers published on the
subject of global cooling in total over
the 60s and 70s steadily increasing but
plateauing at the end of the 70s
no more papers were being published on
the subject but why well let's plot on
the same graph the total number of
papers published on the subject of
global warming so the heating of the
planet by greenhouse gases there was not
a single year in the 1960s 70s or any
decades since in which global cooling
was the prevailing theory in the
scientific community so why did
scientists change their mind and flip
from global cooling to global warming
well they didn't global warming has
always been the consensus in the
scientific community when you measure
the peer-reviewed publications this idea
of the big global cooling scare of the
1970s and that scientists changed their
mind is a myth it's simply not supported
by the data some scientists were
concerned about the idea of the earth
entering into a new ice age for the
exact reasons that I just outlined and
so would you presented with only that
information you would draw the same
conclusion logically however those
scientists concerned about global
cooling were not considering the
elephant in the room the topic of the
fourth research group greenhouse gases
after an aerosol induced ice age was
first posited in that letter to
President Nixon and in a scientific
paper by Russell and Schneider in 1971
subsequent publications including some
by those original authors found that the
hypothesis had overestimated how much
cooling aerosols would produce and at
the same time had underestimated how
much warming greenhouse gas emissions
like carbon dioxide would produce is the
more carbon dioxide the humans put is
the
fear the more heat is trapped causing
warming and the whole thing becomes a
question of balance of all of these
facts at some of them negative producing
cooling like aerosols and some of them
positive producing warming like carbon
dioxide what is the net total effect on
the world's climate since the 1970s
researchers have been investigating all
the pieces of the climate puzzle
individually but they've also been
putting the puzzle together scientists
have looked at changes in this solar
radiation arriving at earth and shown
that well it's had a pretty tiny
influence I mean the Sun is very
important without it I mean I don't need
to explain why the Sun is important but
my point here is that there haven't been
any significant solar changes and so
there hasn't been a significant
influence on the world's temperature
change we also look at human influence
on the climate and we now understand
that aerosols have overall probably had
a cooling effect although there's still
a lot to understand about these pesky
particles but by far the biggest piece
of the climate puzzle and you're going
to be so shocked by this is greenhouse
gases most importantly carbon dioxide
the warming from these gases has been
amplified by water vapor which is also a
greenhouse gas putting together the
pieces of this climate puzzle we see
that the heating from these gases far
outweighs any other influence and
honestly this is what we'd expect
without natural co2 in the atmosphere
the world would be far too cold for
comfort so it would be pretty bizarre
if pumping billions more tons of this
gas into the atmosphere didn't
substantially heat things up there's
still uncertainty of course for a given
scenario of future human emissions we
can't be sure whether we're in for 3
degrees or 5 degrees of global warming
but one thing is clear
greenhouse gases are by far the biggest
piece of
global temperature puzzle so if we don't
stop emitting them we know we're in for
a picture of more and more global
warming starting in 1978 with a seminal
paper by James Hansen and his colleagues
science figured out that the net total
effect of humans on the planet is global
warming with the cooling effect of
aerosols being outweighed by the warming
effects of greenhouse gases and sure
enough since the 1970s we have seen
undeniable warming the apparent cooling
phase of the 40s was actually primarily
in the northern hemisphere alone while
the southern hemisphere continued to
warm and that cooling phase has given
way to decade on decade of global
warming the world is approximately 1
degrees Celsius warmer now than it was
in the 1970s contrary to what a lot of
online commenters think this is bang-on
what James Hansen predicted would happen
back in the 80s and we can be extremely
confident therefore this warming trend
is going to continue we have the science
nailed down what we as scientists now
all need to do is get better at
predicting how much warming is going to
take place in the future and what the
consequences of that warming will be and
that means understanding better how
changes in economic activity will change
emissions of greenhouse gases and
understanding things like feedback loops
which will determine if signals that we
put into the climate get amplified by
natural processes ongoing research is
absolutely crucial if we are to avoid
catastrophic warming we know that we
need to bring our net emissions of
greenhouse gases down to zero and that's
going to take effort from individuals
such as by flying less by eating less
meat and by changing energy providers to
those using renewable sources but it's
also going to take structural change
which means we need action from
governments which is why protests like
the recent climate strike are so
incredibly important we need action both
from the bottom up and from the top down
together the scientific debate about
whether we are warming or cooling the
planet is over it has been forward
decades and it's also been clear for
decades that the predicted warming is
really happening and is really serious
what is needed now is not debate because
it's not going to get us anywhere what
is needed now is action to protect our
children and ourselves from the effects
of that warming before it gets any worse
if you enjoyed this video then there's a
good chance you are interested in the
future trajectory of the Earth's climate
whether that's warmer or cooler I'll
give you a hint though it's warming and
so you may have seen the recent IPCC
report on warming in the world's oceans
like all IPCC reports it's a somewhat
baffling array of graphs with large
uncertainties and multiple possible
futures if you want to get better at
understanding these reports and graphs
in general then you should check out a
course on statistics on brilliant org
brilliant is a mix of interactive
quizzes exercises and beautifully
explained problems that bring learning
about even potentially dry topics like
statistics to life the interactive
problems in particular are really fun
I've said before that I wish brilliant
had been around when I was at school
and I really do mean that in particular
I've really disliked statistics when I
first learned them and a tool like
brilliant would have helped me out
immeasurably but whether you're a school
a college or simply interested adult
learning about maths and science through
the site is easy fun and you can even do
it on your commute you can use parts of
brilliant for free and if the expertly
written courses sound good to you then
check out brilliant org forward slash
Simon Clark and the first 200 people to
use promo code Simon Clarke will get 20%
off their premium annual subscription
thank you for watching the video and a
very special thanks must go to dr. Adam
levy for helping me out with making it
say hi Adam hello Adam
for the record Simon made me make that
awful joke if you're interested in
learning more about the Earth's climate
or about climate change then go and
check out Adams YouTube channel so I
started my youtube channel when I was
still studying for my doctorate in
atmospheric physics at the University of
Oxford climate change can be so
overwhelming and I wanted to make videos
that made it
a bit more straightforward and
approachable and that's what climate
Adam is it's a place where we can all
have a slightly less stressful climate
chat go and subscribe to Adams Channel
and you can subscribe to this one as
well if you liked this and want to see
more and if you did enjoy the video pop
it alike let me know what you thought in
the comments and also give it a share if
there's someone who you think might
enjoy this video do give it a share on
your social because it really helps
spread the video
that's everything ago I say really um
thanks for watching I'll see in the next
one